guys we got the dates for 2023 locked
maybe a couple more added Phoenix I'll
see you guys September 29th and the 30th
La Jolla I'll be back October 20th
through the 22nd Salt Lake City finally
coming back October 27th and the 28th
hoping to see you all out there Batavia
Illinois my first time going there very
excited coming on November 10th and
November 11th and San Francisco to close
out the year at Cobbs cannot wait to get
back to one of my favorite cities in the
country December 8th and 9th all tickets
are available on my website at
ryansickler.com
I'm very excited to announce that I have
teamed up with blonde medicine and I am
releasing the audio for my special Lefty
son as an album it drops Friday
September 22nd everywhere you get music
iTunes Apple music Spotify you name it
it'll be out there very excited go check
it out support my special on YouTube
thank you very much I'm very excited to
announce that we have partnered with
Spotify it changes absolutely nothing
for you the added benefit though is that
you now get video on Spotify you're
gonna get the Honeydew audio and video
on Spotify we're very excited to partner
with Spotify it changes absolutely
nothing for you you're not having to pay
for anything or anything nothing's
behind a paywall none of that you just
now able to get audio and video
on Spotify so go subscribe to the
Honeydew on Spotify today
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media and I want to say thank you
thank you again for your support of this
show it's a tough show uh especially uh
when you're trying to get past the
YouTubes and the algorithms and
everything wherever you're talking about
real stuff and sometimes that's frowned
upon you know what I'm saying so thank
you for supporting Please Subscribe go
watch my special Lefty son on my YouTube
channel share it get it out there
um and look if you have to have more
then you gotta have the patreon I'm
telling you listen to me it's five bucks
there's no tears no levels no nothing if
you sign up for a year you get over a
month worth of episodes free get the
Honeydew a day early get it ad free no
extra cost and the stories the Honeydew
with y'all y'all got the wildest stories
I've ever heard in my life there's no
comparison I say every week what are we
going to hear now then we hear a guy who
we talked to a guy who's parachute
didn't open and he crashed into the
ground in front of his mom okay yeah
we talked to a double Lunt waves history
double lung transplant a double lung
transplant and then the dude stole the
guy's girl and his breath okay I'm
telling you we've had a we've had a
people who've died non-stop we've had a
girl with two [__] as I've said all
the time we've had a girl with three
anuses okay we've had a cold case solved
five bucks cup of coffee you get
hundreds of episodes all right that's
all I'm gonna say about it come see me
on tour if I am in your town when you're
around what do we got coming up here
let's see September 29th and 30th
Phoenix Arizona October 20th and through
the 22nd excuse me that's La Jolla
that's three nights October 27 the 28th
Salt Lake City November 10th and 11th
Batavia Illinois in December 8th and 9th
San Francisco California all right
that's it y'all you know what we're
doing over here we're highlighting the
low lights these are the stories behind
the storytellers and I am very excited
to have this guest back on the Honeydew
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome Mark
Norman welcome welcome back to the
Honeydew hey hey good to be here well
you gotta go easy with the following I'm
throbbing here thank you for the
flowering I'm hungover and gay I'll keep
it down now it's a wild night
um comedy's booming in this town you
feel every every club's giving you
drinks and hanging out did you are you
having a good time out here I love it I
love it I mean for uh for a minute you
know you go downtown you get a fentanyl
shot up your ass but uh for now I'm
staying on Sunset it's all you need
that's all you need dude I'm walking
from the Improv to the store did you
really that's a good that's a good walk
it's not a bad walk at all 15-minute
walk that's nothing it's less than a
mile exactly put a podcast in listen to
the set go there go there no one walks
yeah
nobody walks out here or the subway no
one's doing that either there's reasons
oh really yeah dude it's scary yeah this
these are just I mean listen no scare
more scarier than New York subways but
you know well I went down there
yesterday here and it's uh it's quite a
gathering yeah yeah it's empty yeah the
empty is empty clean Subway scarier than
hobo knife busy Subway agreed
um well look first before we get into
anything plug and oh is that my ex she's
a real dog
plug and promote everything oh please
sorry I'm ranting and raving I got a hot
special out Soup To Nuts check it out
Holocaust r word slavery we cover it all
trans gay Cliffs and uh I'm on the road
yeah you don't say tour doing all the
dates coming to Europe
marknomahcomedy.com check out we might
be drunk on Tuesdays with stories
that's it
um all right man well I'm very excited
to have you back because we were talking
about before this is this this you
haven't been back since the ymh days
yeah and this is the second Studio since
then so it's nice to have you back it's
a beauty man you you've come up in the
world thank you buddy and great art on
the walls you got a nice lady over there
it's Kirsten out there working killing
it you gotta you got a gay dog now yeah
all in bro you're from here no I'm in
Baltimore Baltimore yeah holy [__] you
got out I got out that's a rough town I
got out good for you you burn that CVS
and you got the hell out of there
dude you see the one with the front door
on it oh yeah it's got a front [__]
door on that TV
like somebody's house right right Gillis
will send me crazy videos and he sent me
one of uh you see the social worker
going to the projects in Baltimore and
they beat the [__] out of him no oh dude
it's it's dark he's just going in and
they're [__] him up yeah he's like a
you know he's like a hero activist like
I want to help the black community and
he pulls up he's like a nerdy white guy
and he just gets out of their the car
and they just start wailing on him and
then he's like trying to get back in the
car and one of them's on the roof
hitting him like on the top of the head
it's crazy yeah it's where I'm from
there you go you know that's why you're
humble we call it New Orleans of the of
the mid-atlan yes sir so tell me um I
want to get into it because I know you
had a very different upbringing yeah um
and it and it says here you you were in
a car chase as a private school teen so
this surprised me so you went he
actually went to private school yeah I
went to Catholic school because uh I
went to public school you know
kindergarten to eighth grade and it was
pretty dicey a lot of fights a lot of uh
tension you know mixing a lot of mixing
and uh I think my dad was like your
grades are hell you're an idiot it's
scary over there in the public school
we're putting you in private for four
years let's just try it and I I wasn't
I'm an atheist you know my parents we
never had religion even then you were
yeah yeah it was just never a part of my
life it wasn't like God isn't real I
just I didn't know about it right the
only time I knew about church is I'd
sleep at a friend's house on Saturday
and you'd have to wake up you know at
the sleepover when you're 10 and go to
the church with them
you ever do that okay yeah yeah yes
weird yeah it is we I was I grew up
Catholic so when I would go see like I'd
go to what temple with Jewish friends
I'd go see methodists and I was like
these are way better way better
everything's so somber and everything's
so bull you know just oh that Catholic
[__] forever and ever
and then turn around you know what's
funny that I can get up in front of it
doesn't matter how many people I can get
up in front of them and be comfortable
enough to go out there and tell jokes to
thousands of strangers sure but that
[__] when they would tell you in church
turn around and peace be with you yes
biggest anxiety really you didn't mind
that I thought that was the best part I
don't want to hear about Lazarus or uh
Exodus or whatever the [__] you are
either though I just like oh there's
something to do now you know and it's
not a Psalm or a thing a dumb Rhythm to
it you know what I never knew this [__]
man it was all clueless on so I like
that I could do that
I
didn't know
because I didn't know you had to do this
yeah yeah and you know it's not that's
weird yeah and you're a kid they want
you to stick your tongue out so they can
put that on your toes like yeah put it
in my hands exactly he was an inch away
from calling me a Jew she was like come
on you [__] deep take the take the
thing and do that I didn't know anything
I'm not even Jewish but I could I
thought I could tell he thought I was
you could tell you thought yeah
uh okay so is this this is an all-boy
school no it's a co-ed okay it's uniform
and it's mass and all that [__] so walk
me through a day I mean a day is uh you
get there what are you what's your
uniform what colors are you wearing
charcoal plant pants black shoes white
T-shirt tucked in you know button not
t-shirt white button down De La Salle
Crest and uh you could you could throw a
hoodie on a school hoodie or something
like that so that was pretty much it I
never washed it I had the yellow armpits
because you know you just have like
three shirts you just wear them for the
rest of your life and uh it was Uptown
New Orleans which was a trek for us and
it was a nice area the whole thing was a
culture shock it was a culture shock in
the sense that this is the first time
what you're seeing people with money or
in a different class than you money
Catholic private all the rules I never
wore a uniform in my life I was just
like a I don't say latchkey kid but I
was just like a dumbass feral dude you
know I was running around and uh jizz on
the pants you know bad hair braces I was
a mess and this was like high school
armpit hair girls you know it was super
awkwardness yeah I would go to school in
sweatpants you know and I was always the
kid with the shoes untied I don't know
why I think I had a helmet I was an
idiot but uh yeah this was a big change
for me I never know how to pray I didn't
know what assembly was I didn't know
what Mass was so big shift
and were you the only kid like that
where these kids already assimilated or
did you find some kids where they they
were like I don't know what the [__]
going on either well it's one of those
high schools that started in eighth
grade okay you know those yeah that was
news to me so they all knew each other
I've heard of that I mean ours wasn't
either ours was ninth grade oh yeah oh
yeah so they already knew each other
from that year too exactly so I felt
like the odd man you know I'm not
religious I I don't do private this is
all new and they knew each other so it
was a I almost shot the school up you
know as I was right there I felt so out
of place
but we made it work we made friends and
you adapt and you figure it out and it
was fine
but made a lot of friends we did a lot
of pranks a lot of fun times uh met some
great gals you know girlfriends and
whatnot uh but
point being getting to the story
senior year you know that last week of
senior year where you're like all right
it it's coming to an end there's an
energy in the air you know you got your
prom you got your graduation you got
it's ending you're gonna go to college
holy [__] this is wild so that last week
was just like party central you know
every you're a senior you own the
[__] school you know everybody so it
was that last week
two days before graduation there's a
place in New Orleans called The Fly
that's what we called it was like a
giant park on the water on the
Mississippi River everybody would just
go there and drink that was like fist
fights with the fly make out at the fly
you know uh crawfish boil at the fly we
gotta can't get the fly it was always
the fly I don't know why it's called
that but we're out at the fly we got
kegs all day it was like a half day so
we went straight to the fly kegs
drinking drinking drinking I had a 1971
Cutlass Supreme convertible yeah oh it
was a beauty it was a it was it was uh
black guys would always pull up and go
how much you want to sell it it was like
a hoopty but it was a great looking car
uh always at the top down the top was
ripped so I just left it down I would
let it rain in there you would yeah oh
yeah and everybody loved the car it was
a great car so we're drinking at the fly
and then my buddy goes Jay's having a
big house Party House Parties were
everything back then that's me too how
old are you now I'm 39. oh man I've got
you by 11 years but still that was that
was the thing too House parties and
field parties field parties yeah if you
didn't have a house we would just meet
in a field there you go yeah that's what
the fly was it just just grass with the
trees all right and uh you know a lot of
pickup trucks somebody throws the music
on and you're good to go on fire and
yeah yeah
so party at Jay's house we've been
drinking for hours you know senior in
the uniform going at it and uh we go all
right I'll drive to Jay's me and my
buddy wait have I told this on here oh
[__] it doesn't matter I don't remember
[__] well me and my buddy Packy he was a
little kid his last name was like
pakinski so everybody just called him
Packy but he was one of these kids he
was like a a sophomore but he was this
tall and he was the wildest kid on the
planet he was like a Stevo so everybody
liked him because he would he would just
go up to a guy and just call him a
racial slur you're like hey it's five
bucks go call that Asian guy whatever
not not to be mean but just like to see
if he would do it he was a guy who would
jump off that into the pool well yeah go
punch that kid in the face yeah he would
just do anything right eat this pill he
would eat it you know and now he's you
know roofied or whatever so he was just
that kid and everybody loved him because
he was just pure entertainment this is
pre-internet you needed that kid yeah
yeah so it's me and Becky you know I got
a [__] 15 year old in my car and
we're driving and it's rush hour it's
like five o'clock so we're trying to get
across town we've been drinking all day
uniform on and I'm trying to get off I
gotta get off of this exit and I go can
I get in it's bumper to bumper and this
guy's like nah no dice and I was like
jeez man like he was super mean I'm
drunk he was like no you're not getting
in [__] you kind of thing so I was like
all right screw this guy so I got in
behind him and I just gave him a tap a
bumper tap on purpose you did on purpose
just to be like hey hey
you're a douche which I was the totally
the douche you know I'm a young [__]
young dumb and full of [__] you know just
coming out of my eyes
so I gave him the bumper tap so that
he's like what the hell he's going nuts
in the mirror he's like are you crazy
we're all like ah you know [__] with
him me and Packy and then uh I bump him
again you know it it got good to me yeah
I liked it it felt good yeah so I bump
him again and now he just puts the card
Park it's bumper to bumper gets out how
big is this dude he's kind of like a
he's a tall wiry guy the older older I'd
say like
maybe 40. okay and as a kid when you see
a 40 year old that's an adult but he had
a tank top on and long hair and it's
like he kind of was a little uh a little
crunchy you know maybe a little surfery
hacky City yeah but he was grizzled like
he had a white kind of a white facial
hair and he'd been around he'd probably
been to a dead show and he's done peyote
and uh he's got a scruffy dog so he was
a weird character but he you know he
looked like he had some some characters
in his life
dead wife who the hell
yeah
he was he was a little he's bringing the
heat yeah this guy was no joke and wait
real quick please when he gets out of
the car do you are you like yeah let's
go or do you have that moment oh [__]
like do you have like what what hit you
first I definitely had the old [__] like
oh cause you're drunk and you think
you're invisible profits are driving
drunk and tapping him yes drawing way
too much attention to yourself 100 I
thought he's a he's a grown-up he's not
gonna fight us you know but
at the time you said yeah he was like a
sophomore 18 17 17 18. yeah so about to
graduate yeah feeling good got the world
is my anal
oh sorry a little semen
so he gets out of the car and he starts
walking towards us and he just slams his
fist on the hood like like a gorilla
like ah and your Top's down tops down oh
you're an easy target oh yeah and uh I
think we're smoking in there he just
slams the thing we're like Jesus Christ
and then he walks past me and I was kind
of like oh here we go and he goes to the
back of my car looks at the license
plate kind of memorize it and then he
gets back and he goes in his car I was
like huh that was weird all right I
thought that was gonna be a lot worse so
now I bump him again no I couldn't help
it I am I'm almost in a blackout by the
way it has been like six hours of Miller
lights and a keg
so I'm like all right traffic kind of
opens up once we get off the highway or
the freeway and now I'm on the street
level I'm on Magazine Street and race I
remember this and I I hit we're going up
I'm following him he hits a red lights
coming up so he stops at the end of the
intersection so now I'm stuck in the
intersection you know he knew what he
was doing so now I'm just like about to
get T-boned here I'm like oh [__] I
can't get around him
he's on his phone
before I know it there's a bar on the on
the left side of me a guy runs out of
the bar
leather vest you know chain wallet jeans
boots biker guy
he runs out of the bar and jumps in my
car I swear to God he jumps in and I was
like ah I mean this guy's terrified he's
definitely killed a gay guy you know
this guy was he had like a tooth earring
you know chains all over him tattoos
terrifying
yeah yeah he was not [__] around he
was a Hell's Angel or whatever you want
to call it one of those groups he just
jumped right in your [__] car he
jumped right in and it was there was no
like hey buddy it was just it was just
him
so this is the this is where nobody
believes me so I am freaking out um you
know the you realize like I'm a child
what am I doing here so you got two kids
yes we're in high school uniforms for
Christ's sake so he's in the back seat
and he he kind of I started kind of
trying to drive when he I didn't know
what he was doing but I couldn't get
away but I got a little bit of inch up
or moved a little and he jumped in he
kind of was half in half out so his legs
are dangling outside of the car but his
body in front part of the top part of
the body is in the back seat so I was
like ah and this again Packy wild man
Fearless
he jumps in the back seat and they're
going at it no I swear to God because he
had an advantage because the guy was
kind of like he's got his torso in the
car exactly
yeah exactly
so I
hope and I just go you know cut through
traffic
you know and I'm like oh the guy's still
hanging in the car he's kind of crawled
in but he's a little uh he's a little
wonky because he's trying to get his
footing and I'm driving and swerving and
they're going at it in the back seat and
obviously this guy is getting the best
to pack he's a 15 year old yeah soaking
wet he's a hundred pounds you know and
they're just going and I'm like push him
out push him out I'm freaking out I
don't know I'm trying to do one of these
you know like grab the guy a little bit
and uh Packy just got that that [__]
strength I don't know the adrenaline and
he pushed him out did he he pushed him
out and I remember looking back and he's
you know like out of a movie just the
rolling on the cement
and I was like ah what the [__] oh my
God I can't believe what's happening so
Packy comes up front he's a little
banged up but he's like oh my God that
was crazy
this guy must have been 55 I mean he's
definitely been in a lot of scuffles and
then the war
this guy might have been enough he had a
[__] he was huffing glue back in the
the 40s who knows
so he's uh we're we we drive a little
bit and we pull over we just have to
like regroup we're just like oh my
[__] god what is happening is that
guy alive is he dead did he get hit by
another car yeah where's the other guy
is he still around I mean it was it was
insanity
so we kind of come to and I had a beeper
aging myself I had a beeper and it was
uh it was saying like Jay's house or par
here's the address here's the address
and it's going off and I'm like all
right let's go to this party we'll just
have a drink take it easy tell everybody
the story
so
cut to us at the party where the kings
of the party I'm holding courts I'm in
the living room telling everybody the
story some girl might be into me I'm
killing and uh Packy pushed him out
everybody's high-fiving Packie great
time House part like classic out of a
movie you know uh just [__] toilet
paper hanging them from everything
everybody's got Solo cups and music's
playing and my beeper's going off like
crazy you know it's probably like nine
at night at this point just like 9-1-1
9-1-1 mom mom mom and I'm like uh so I
get my best phone voice you know and I
call my mom and I go hello how are you
what's up and she's like get the [__]
home right now the police are here oh
[__] I was like ah [__] I was like well
I'm out I'm out what are you talking
about I'm trying to play dumb she's like
get home shut up [__] you get home and I
was like ah
so this is where it gets interesting
this is where
[Laughter]
so I'm hammered you know I'm like lights
out gone Blotto smashed and I'm going
home I gotta go home I tell everybody
they're like oh you're [__] dude
what's going on oh my God you shouldn't
be driving I'm like I gotta go home my
friend goes wait before you leave and he
hands me a big jar of Jiff
peanut butter peanut butter yeah any
friend of mine used to do this too eat a
Gob of it I just put my hand in he's and
he's like you can't smell booze over the
peanut butter which I didn't know did
you know that I only have I only know it
because a friend of mine would do this
he swore by it too I never tried it
though yeah I mean I even swore by it
they'd keep it in the glove box just in
case they got pulled over instead of not
drinking and driving yeah they would
actually buy peanut butter yes exactly
he would also I'm not even kidding you
he would also wear a priest costume
sometimes I swear to God come on I swear
to god wow he purposely bought a wagon
get out of it instead of not drinking
driving he caught a wagon up I swear to
God a priest costume and he would eat
peanut butter does he have kids no yeah
you don't want to beat him he's had them
oh geez that's a bad look he's driving a
wagon with a priest outfit a couple of
kids in there you're like no no they're
my kids that's not a good look
so go ahead you have P you eat a Gob of
peanut butter peanut butter I haul ass
home uh I get to the house there's three
cop cars outside the whole thing and I'm
like oh God but again when you're so
drunk you kind of just like accept
everything like ah what whatever happens
happens I wasn't that scared because I
was I was basically in a blackout but
you also didn't think at all like well
here's my chance to stay where I'm at
deal with this later so I don't get a
DUI or they don't see me drunk that
didn't even register it didn't register
because the the way my mom was on the
phone was like I don't give a [__] you
better get here exactly like you're
we're gonna come find you if you don't
come here so I was like all right let me
just get this over with and again you're
drunk so you're like all right I'll deal
with this [__] it so I get home there's
cop cars outside I walk in
swing that door open there's three cops
drinking tea in the living room with my
two parents
and I'm like oh my God so I show up and
they're like what the hell they pop up
and uh you know what the hell we heard
this we heard that a guy is in the
hospital because he jumped out of your
car what the blood and I'm like whoa I
don't know any I played I denied the
whole thing which is so crazy so then
the cops go you've been drinking I go no
no they smelled my breath got by which
is insane they go outside they go that's
the plate we got the plate and I was
like there I don't know anything you're
talking about you guys are crazy this is
what I was at a party what are you
talking about I've been out all night
you know and they're like no no no and
you know after about an hour I just
caved I was like all right he was in my
car we my friend pushed him out I bumped
a guy on the highway blah blah blah and
that was it they didn't arrest you or
anything no nothing are you gonna have
to admitted it yeah I I don't know uh I
was like I bumped the guy on accident
okay and three times three times and uh
I was like yeah I've been drinking and
nothing came of it I don't know I know
that's a horrible ending but that's the
greatest [__] enemy you can wish for
if you're you yeah it was pretty good I
think my parents took my car away for
like a month I mean whatever yeah but it
was a different time this is like late
90s whether it's like well you're okay
they're okay I think I paid the guys
hospital bills uh he broke his hand
turns out that's it falling out of the
car yeah broke his hand I think the
other guy had some some priors I think
the long-haired guy had some stuff so
they're like he's not gonna press
charges but you know you got to be
careful I got the speech lost the car
and I think it helped I was 17. yeah you
know you're a minor still here yeah and
that was it I mean I swear to God is it
a white privilege I don't know what you
want to call it but got lectured by the
parents they put me in alcohol
counseling what's how's that different
than uh AAA I think it's for kids it's
different I had to go to the this lady
and she she was like are your parents
abusing you and I remember being like Oh
I could really get him on this one
and I was like no no no no I'm not and
uh yeah I had to take a bunch of tests
and go to therapy for a few sessions but
that was it it was like therapy was the
punishment and I was like I'll take it
I'll take that any day yeah so I feel
bad just dropping it off a cliff but
that's what happened I I got by that's
the story that's it staying hydrated
isn't only for the athletes and
champions in this world it's a daily
maintenance every single person needs
proper functional hydration is essential
and liquid IV is the number one powder
hydration brand in America they're
hydration multiplier is the one product
you're missing in your daily routine
with just one stick you can hydrate two
times faster than water alone plus get
essential vitamins and three times the
electrolytes as leading sports drinks
all right you know I love liquid Ivy
they've been with us for a long time my
favorite one still is the Citrus orange
I love it uh we have it here at the
studio we give it out to people all the
time they take it we use it take it on
tour it's a great way to stay hydrated
especially look I have a lot of people
who drink I can't drink anymore and they
tell me that legit helps them in the
mornings after hangovers things like
that so liquid IV believes that
Equitable access to clean and abundant
water is the foundation of a healthier
World they partner with leading
organizations to fund and Foster
innovative solutions that help
communities protect both their water and
their Futures real people real flavor
real hydrating grab your liquid IV and
bulk nationwide at Costco or you can get
twenty percent off when you go to liquid
iv.com and use code honeydew at checkout
that's 20 off of anything when you shop
better hydration today using promo code
honeydew and liquid iv.com
now let's get back to the do tell us
this one about this uh wild Midwest Road
gig oh this happened two weeks ago this
is not right really all right fresh hell
yeah all right that that buckle up
because this has some twists and turns
it's a roller coaster of of jizz here
all right
so got a gig in Davenport Iowa I had a
special coming out and I'm I need new
material so I told my agent book me in
some weird off-market places don't go to
Denver don't go to Austin don't go to
Phoenix book Chicopee Mass Lancaster PA
Davenport Iowa get me in the in the
sticks so he puts me in Davenport Iowa
the flight is a [__] American Airlines
stinks sucks the worst so I have a
flight to Chicago at 8 A.M Chicago
connect
land in Moline
Iowa which is about 15 minutes from
Davenport so I go all right I can do
this flight gets canceled uh I'm like ah
[__] so now I'm up all night like what
do I do I'm texting the agent hey
flights canceled I don't know what to do
there's no flights out of Moline it's
not looking good maybe we'll fly you to
Chicago and then you get a car so we did
that so we flew to Chicago
got a car
that flight was delayed so now I landed
in in Chicago at like nine at night and
it's a three hour drive or four hour
drive so I missed the gig
but it was a two two Friday two Saturday
or two Saturday two Sunday whatever it
was so I missed the first two yeah so
the half your money's gone it's gone but
the agent goes let's put one of those
shows because it was sold out it's a
tiny room the room's about the size of
this one
sold out so we'll move one of the shows
to
the next nights and I have three on
Sunday
so we lost one show I can deal with that
spent the whole day at the airport
brutal land in Chicago I go meet up with
my opener Andrew he's in Chicago too
waiting for me and uh because he had to
connect too but he was like well if
you're in Chicago I'll just drive with
you I was like all right great meet up
with him we go to a hotel like it's been
the longest day of my life I've been up
all night been at the airport all day I
want to kill myself let's just get a
drink and go to bed and then tomorrow he
had the rental car already so like
tomorrow we'll jump in the car we'll go
to Davenport easy peasy shows at five
o'clock then seven then nine so we'll
drive there to three four hour drive
we'll leave it 11 A.M we'll get there at
three four we're good to go
we get hammered
Lee just another shot after shot after
shot or in Chicago it's a great City
great town and it's it's Saturday night
or whatever so it's like bumping so we
just got sucked right in so of course we
get [__] housed and then we did that
thing that the stupidest thing you do
with buddies where you get hammered the
bars close you go to your hotel his room
is a door Two Doors Down for Mine we sit
in the room and talk till like six in
the morning
so now we wake up but we're supposed to
get up at nine to leave at 10 or
whatever we wake up at like noon
so we're banged up we're on no sleep we
wake up at noon we go get lunch and then
we just start driving now he got a
rental car and the only two options the
rental car business is [__] right but
something's going on
he got a he either could get an F-150 or
a Chevy bolt electric yep so what would
you have got the 150 really yeah he was
like that's too much car we're doing in
a long distance it's gonna be a gas
guzzer I'll get the electric yeah I want
to be comfy huge mistake
huge [__] electric uh [__] musk [__] all
you queefs cause those things stink the
Tesla's not bad but any other electric
car is bad news
so we getting the electric car it's
fully charged and we're driving three
and a half hour drive it just starts
that energy bar is going down like a
video game and we're looking at it we're
like an hour in it's down it went
started at 250 and it was down to like
68 and we're like we got three two more
hours here this is We're not gonna make
it let's go charge it so we go truck but
we're up against it so we find we're
going we're in Chicago we get as far as
uh Rochelle not uh Dan Van Kirk from
Russia my dog out there Princess Lily
Rose is from Rochelle really born in
Rochelle Illinois small small out of a
movie Main Street it's all quiet like uh
the hay seed goes by or whatever that
thing is and we get there we're like all
right we found a charger [__] to find a
charger in the [__] wide open plain
of Midwest you know you find a Tesla one
you can't use that you find this one
that one's broken we found one in the
middle of a church parking lot in
Rochelle and we're like all right let's
go let's get a taco or something while
we wait so we plug it in and we go we'll
give it like 20 minutes that's how long
a Tesla takes and we just start walking
around the town yeah 20 minutes is up we
go back it went from like 54 to 56. and
we're like oh my God this is not gonna
work and it looks on the dash it says
it'll be finished charging at 11 p.m and
we're like oh no we got to be at the gig
at five yeah so we're freaking out we
don't know what to do we're like [__]
you electric God damn it Edison whoever
and uh so Andrew knew Dan Van Kirk no I
did he goes here we go bro look at it
you're not gonna believe it we're in
Rochelle
this town sucks there's no one here our
car is not charged we got to get to
Davenport and he goes I guess you can
use my mom's car
and we're like could we I don't want to
impose this is a big ask but they're
pretty tight those two and he goes yeah
but she's in a assisted living she's an
older lady
so you have to go to the old folks home
get the keys
yeah oh yeah BBK hell yeah baby I mean
without him even before he saved the
whole thing this guy's a is a mensch so
we're already just [__] we're
just trying to get to this dumb gate
we've already missed one night and I I
shouldn't just my agent's like you can
cancel man the room's the size of your
dick it's tiny you know [__] it and I
was like I'm doing it I'm doing the gig
so
go to the old folks home in the electric
car
and you know you gotta check in it's
Walkers it's respiratory [__] you know
it's it's bleak
if we go up take the elevator knock
knock I don't want to insult the lady
but you know hunched over Kane old
school quilt over her you know never
even could look at me because she was so
hunched it was like she never gave one
of these and saw me she didn't do a
thriller
you know she was just hunched over and
she goes while you're here I have no no
one ever visits me
could you move my my electric uh old
lady kind of Craftmatic chair is broken
and she's like I have another one in the
bedroom could you swap it out they're
like of course you got it happy to help
we appreciate you giving us a car you
got it so we're two strapping hungover
dudes these things weigh 9 million
pounds they got a motor in it they're
electric it's brutal I hate electric
everything electric sucks
so
now we're hooked we're sweating out
[__] vodka tonic so we move this
thing over we unplug it and uh it's got
you know crumbs and [__] all over it we
go to the bedroom get the other one we
move that in the whole thing takes
forever because you got to take breaks
they're so heavy you're like all right
shut it down put it down
so we finally moved the the chairs we
get the keys
she got a Ford Escape Hallelujah gas
powered car so we go okay his uncle
lives there let's put the electric car
at his uncle's house we'll put in the
driveway and we'll plug it in yeah
you're using the whole extended family
over there yeah I love it I love it the
van Kirks
and we go we'll put the electric cars in
his uncle's electricity yeah we had to
open his garage find an outlet uh the
neighbors were like what the [__] is
happening here so we got the Ford Escape
and I go look we've had a harrowing day
let's get some Wendy's let's do a little
treat let me get some Frosty yeah and
Andrew starts pulling his wallet I gotta
come on I got it I'm the headliner these
are you know 109. I can swing two
frosties so we got a couple jbc's and a
couple nuggets get the frosty I throw my
Wild on the dash you know make sure I
got all the right money
we go to the house we plug it in we got
the Ford Escape it's fully uh jackassed
up we go we're gonna make it God damn it
what a night or what a day brutal we
just start driving ah we're gonna make
it holy [__] the gigs at five
so we got to Davenport Iowa in this Ford
Escape at about 4 38. we just made it
and we go let's just check into the
hotel but then you gotta think
he's still got to get this rental car
back he's still stuck with his car I'm
flying out of Davenport
so what are we gonna do there but he's
like I'll go get it or we'll figure it
out so I was like all right all right
but I might have to fly out of Davenport
tomorrow or Moline uh and he's like oh
we'll figure it out so we get to the
hotel and the gigs you know the clock's
ticking the gigs in like 22 minutes and
they go all right you want to check in
credit card and I go where the hell is
my wallet
I left it on the dash of the electric
carcass Frosty
[Music]
Frosty Frosty Dave Thomas you [__]
oh God so now we have three shows ahead
of us we're hungover we're on No Sleep
we've had the worst day ever they're
about to start about to start we go to
the gig
um
you know we do the three shows it's fine
we sell merch I mean we really did it up
and I did three hours of Comedy you know
and uh flipping the room the whole thing
so now we go all right here's what we'll
do
we'll get back in the gas car
drive to
the uncle's house Rochelle yeah get my
wallet um then I had a you know Moline
to Chicago Chicago to New York so I said
let's just drive to Chicago we'll get
another hotel room
and I'll just take the second flight
home and he'll do the same great we're
he's furious at me he's like you forget
your wallet what the hell it was going
so well blah blah blah
so we get the wallet we go back and we
go the car is probably charged so we can
drop the Ford Escape off get back to the
electric car it's been hours it's been
like 12 hours we'll just drive that to
Chicago get a hotel drop it off at the
airport in the morning we fly home
we get to the car finally get my wallet
thank God after all this [__]
we checked the car it's been plugged in
it's at like 88. it didn't go up it went
up like 40 notches yeah 88 it's like a
two uh two uh it goes by Miles so the I
think it was like 241 miles to get to
Chicago and it's at 88 miles
so we're like what the [__] is going on
here should we get an Uber my God I
can't believe it and I go I'm so pissed
I'm just gonna drive it I am just gonna
drive it till the wheels fall off I'm
gonna hit the gas heading towards
Chicago and just creep until I get to
Chicago [__] electricity [__] this Vault
bolt whatever
um he goes well what if we put it on
cruise control that maybe you'll use
less because I was going like 95 that's
that's what was burning it out yeah we
get on cruise control and we're we're
we're we're making it it's working but
cruise control slow
so it turned into a three and a half
hour ride was now like a five hour ride
because I'm going like 52 down the
highway because if you go faster it kept
dropping so I'm watching it Go 78 77 76
and I'm just like it was like Thelma and
Louise were holding hands you know I got
the wheel like ah [__] we're going
all the way and we made it with like two
notches left because you know it's like
a car on E it's still got a little life
in it yeah so we got there and he goes
now it's that weird thing of like we're
home let's get a hotel room let's go to
bed we got an airport hotel and he's
like well I have to drive this in the
morning so I can't have it dead so I
said all right
it's [__] six in the morning my
flight's at nine that means you gotta
get there at eight whatever so we sit in
a Best Buy parking lot charging it no
all right we had to I couldn't leave a
soldier you know you just want to go to
bed so now we're charging it it's quiet
we hate each other it's the worst night
of our Lives we're charging we're
charging it gets up to like six and we
go all right six is enough to get to the
rental car place
we parked the car we go to the hotel
we forgot to book two rooms
so we have to sleep in the same bed I
mean it's like a John Hughes movie it's
plain strange those aren't pillows it
really is so now we're sleeping in the
same bed I get like you know 20 minutes
of shut eye and uh I go to the airport
he gets the car drops it off and we got
home but God damn dude worst gig ever
all for Davenport I hope you appreciate
it you come guzzling Nazis cause it was
uh it was brutal brutal gig but we made
it and the lady got her chair fixed
damn it Kirk saving the day out there
totally saved it we appreciate it
without him pen pals with Roy Scoville
great podcast great pie great guy great
bomb uh oh yeah great mom
um I want to hear this story about being
fired from a huge TV job oh
this is bad this is bad
I love when people get honest so I love
it because people out there see the
finished product yeah I think that guy's
got it all he's probably never been
embarrassed or never anything he just
got all the answers oh no not me I'm I'm
still I have a poor kid mentality you
know just change your flight or get it
go to First Class I'm like I I don't
know who am I getting first class
whatever
young comic bro New York City been
mugged had bed bugs living way out in
Brooklyn day job construction janitor
you name it I was I I just a shitty I
was a [__] kicking comic just trying to
get by open mics the whole thing
I do a set at a club a guy sees me and I
had a good set and he goes you're edgy
you're dark we like that we're looking
for a host to host a show on AOL that's
when AOL said some shine on it you know
we'll pay you five thousand dollars
which at the time was like yeah oh my
Epstein holy [__] this is a lot of money
so they go we'll pay you five grand all
you gotta do is write some jokes and
you're gonna host a Halloween show and
we're gonna do it a week before
Halloween Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday was Halloween so you do
a an hour a day for five days until
Halloween the big big finale
so I said you got it sir I am in and we
wrote a ton of jokes we had a writer's
room and this was a big production they
had a a costume contest on the first day
second day was like uh bobbing for
apples or whatever third day was candy
rating you know it was a hole to do
so he kept saying we like that you're
Reggie be edgy we want some some stank
on this show you know it's the Internet
it's the Wild West sayol it's not TV I
said great and we wrote for two weeks we
built sets I got to know everybody it
was great
first show Monday here we go baby you're
gonna do a costume contest then you're
gonna put on a dress and do a cute uh a
man on the street in drag you are I am
okay so that was that was Monday and
then Tuesday was another thing and then
Wednesday was another thing whatever so
we have it all mapped out we got
storyboards we got big wall of white
boards up there with all this [__] all
these jokes on it and has this been run
through people is it approved by anyone
or is it just you and your crew working
on this it's their crew I'm just the
host but I wanted to be Hands-On I've
never made this kind of money in my life
I want to kill it yeah and uh so
everyone's privy to these sketches and
everything oh yeah okay oh yeah it's all
on the up and up everybody loves it
everybody's excited and you know with a
lot of promo AOL with Mark Norman coming
out Halloween spectacular here we go so
it's five days I'm pumped I love it it's
nice to be you know there's coffee there
the snacks of these uh these Studios
it's it's a I was a janitor you know
this is like a a nice little world of
living air conditioning and there was
girls there it was it was great so it
was Showbiz so uh Monday comes around I
got a big night's sleep on Sunday night
here we go Monday morning
time for work
we do the big Halloween contest I got
the Bob Barker skinny mic I got the uh
the fun jacket on and I'm killing it's a
full live audience and a bleacher full
of people in costumes he got Buzz
Lightyear you got a scarecrow you got
Dracula you got everything
couple of hot ladies and you know women
they dress like [__] on Halloween for
some reason which we all appreciate but
uh it's this weird green light to dress
like a skank and God bless you ladies
and comes up I go hey nice horse
accidents you know uh when did you start
walking again you know yeah I'm putting
my own stank on it
this uh Catwoman comes up I'm talking
leather whip you know tight dress big
black hair the cat eyes super sexy joke
so [__] this [__] that you know having
a good time cracks the whip everybody's
great next up African queen beautiful
black woman you know got the neck those
those Rings you know sexy lady hot
outfit and I'm doing this doing that and
I go the the Catwoman's going off and
the African Queen's coming on they pass
each other and I go hey watch that whip
around the African
I thought it was a decent line they said
be edgy I watched the cameras go you
suck yeah I mean they wilted like a
daisy the lights flickered uh the
audience went oh what the [__] was that
I look at the producer he was not into
it
I was so proud of the joke I couldn't
wait to tell it
and uh yeah so you know you have a bomb
it happens you they're not all gonna be
gems so I go all right that one didn't
land but you know on to the next one we
do more jokes more jokes more costumes
more contests
I go immediately from there we wrap up
we have a big thing Applause yay this
guy won he's uh you know uh Joe Biden he
fell down or whatever that was this guy
that was before Joe Biden I don't know
who he was but some guy won
so then I'd get rushed to make up and
I'm putting on full drag like mini skirt
sequin top uh big eyelashes fake eyelash
big red wig Nails makeup lipstick and uh
this guy comes in with a clipboard you
know he's the head honcho and he goes uh
way uh ladies because all these women
are putting [__] on me he goes ladies
can you give me give us the room and I
was like oh boy all right here we go I
got the head honcho in here he's gonna
tell me what's next here we go maybe
good job and he goes we gotta talk and I
can immediately feel like oh this is bad
and I go what's up and he goes
yeah the sponsors
they didn't like uh the whip joke and I
go ah am I fired and he goes yeah
in a week
like the slowest moment of my life and I
was about to go out on the street I was
all geared up to do a q a and a dress I
couldn't wait I had heels on stockings
and he's like yeah you gotta go and I'm
like gotta go we got a whole week of
shoot left he's like we'll find someone
else you're you gotta go and they had
two guys escorted me out in like black
turtlenecks and and Blazers like big
giant in drag yes
I mean I took the wig off and I put my
pants on but I didn't even have time to
scrub so I just was out on Broadway at
[__] 12 30 in the day with [__]
makeup on and eyelashes and nails and
lipstick and I was like I guess that's
it and I went home and I [__] cried
my eyes out I I didn't know what my
mascara
exactly oh
the whole thing and I couldn't believe
it because he said be edgy I remember
calling a comic and they go they never
mean that they don't know what edgy
means that's the problem they don't know
what edgy means no and I thought I was
doing the right thing and uh boy they
were none too please I got escorted out
I went home I scrubbed the makeup off
and uh
I I said well he said be edgy and I'm
emailing with the guy and he didn't want
to pay me he's like oh no you got to get
paid for the work you did he's like you
did a half hour work it's a week-long
shoot I said but I'd love to do the
shoot you fired me he's like well you
went too far and I said well you said be
edgy so we're fighting we're fighting
and we eventually got paid but they
hired some uh like hot girl to do the
rest of it and so she got the gig and I
told her I was like hey don't [__] go
for it you know are you crazy just keep
it on the up and up keep it PG and she
killed it and uh yeah that was that was
the I've been fired a few times but that
was the worst in a dress
for doing what I thought I was supposed
to do it was all very confusing but I
got paid and I got a story out of it
um give me another time you've been
fired
Jesus Christ what's another good one
that's not comedy related uh okay you
said you did a lot of jobs you worked a
lot of jobs a lot of jobs I was a
registrar at New York Film Academy which
is like uh I do the admissions and I do
the if you're absent four times you're
on probation it was the I was the I was
like a disciplined guy I'm a [__]
Chooch I shouldn't be doing that I love
the word chooch and they're making you
also not just keep record but you have
to talk to that person oh God no that's
yeah that's one thing to keep stats for
them yeah I'll keep stats all day but I
had to go talk to the guy you know what
made you take that job I was broke I
lived in New York I went to New York
Film Academy and then I moved there to
be a comedian after that I had graduated
from there and I was like this is the
only place I know in New York so I just
went right back there and I said can I
work here and I I got a job as a file
clerk literally big room full of file
cabinets wall-to-wall and I would they
would hand me a stack this high of
manila folders and I would go in I was
like you guys don't have the internet we
don't have a [__] Excel spreadsheet
we're going 1941 Manila so I would just
file all day at paper cuts and I worked
my way up to registrar because nobody
wanted to do that gig so I'm kicking
kids out who are trying to live their
[__] dreams you're actually having to
kick them out too oh my God I'm from
Poland and I always wanted to come here
and I bet I got no money and I'm like
you gotta go I I don't care but they
care and they're like he's like I'll be
better it's like some 18 year old kid he
just wants to be Tarantino and I'm like
you gotta hit the bricks Pollock and
not good I hate it I hate I got like an
ulcer my hair was falling out I hated
the job because I don't wanna I'm trying
to I'm living my dream in New York I
want to be a comedian and I'm telling
these kids no So eventually I would just
start sliding kids like changing their
numbers you know like hey uh you can
stay I can't kick you out I can't do
this to you yeah you got a house or an
apartment for six months I can't what
what this is crazy so I started cooking
the books did you yeah because I didn't
want to do it anymore I didn't want to
you know fire these kids or get rid of
them and they caught me and I got fired
how'd they catch you well you know the
teacher would be like this kid was never
here he's been absent like uh you know
five days in a month and it says two
days and then they started doing the
numbers and obviously because they still
take attendance and then I would go oh
yeah I would have the main the main uh
sheet and I'd go oh I would erase it it
was all it was so obvious I changed a
six to a one you know it was so obvious
it was all very uh analog and they got
me and I got fired well I was trying to
I was trying to help these kids out
you know these kids they don't know any
of their their language barrier they
live in New York the Subways are brutal
they can went the wrong way they miss
crazy expensive yeah yeah so I couldn't
do it and I got I got next
give me another comedy [__] firing
give me one more well how about this one
how did you told the story about the
Seinfeld stuff last time where oh I did
you ran the light a little bit yeah yeah
yeah I still remember that how about
this one you ever have this I did a gig
in uh Youngstown Ohio not bragging at
the funny farm which is no longer there
it's gone it was a real [__] box just a
piece of garbage club and you ever had
this I'm a young comic I'm broke I'm
happy to be headlining I'm making like
800 bucks for the weekend you lose 500
on the flight you know so I'm just like
do what I gotta do to get by I'm trying
to be I'm trying to play ball and I'm
eating dinner between shows I you know
you can order this side of the menu
whatever I'm eating dinner and the
manager the owner is like you gotta get
the swordfish and I'm like okay you know
it's a free meal I'll get the [__]
swordfish what am I eating and he goes
there's a wine that pairs well with that
I'm like Jesus wine this is this is high
end over here so I drink a bottle of
wine I'm eating swordfish and he's like
you want dessert I was like I'll take
the tiramisu another glass of wine
another glass of wine I'm like all right
I got another show to do here and the
bill comes it's like 312 dollars
this [__] up sold me I would
never get swordfish or wine in my life I
don't even like wine and he he ripped me
and I was like wait what are you talking
about he's like yeah you can only order
from this side of the menu it's like you
know chicken fingers mozzarella sticks
nachos and you got the swordfish I'm
like
so he totally got me and I lost money on
the gig because of the [__] that's
ridiculous
market price swordfish this [__]
he's like it's not a season Ohio and I'm
like I don't care yeah he got me
so I've had clubs hit me up before and
I'll ask you I don't know what's more
offensive I know what's cheaper but I
know it's more offensive I've had clubs
bill me for I don't drink yeah I smoke
uh they'll bill me for a Diet Cokes no
yeah clubs I've had two clubs do it wow
charge me for sodas and I'm like you're
gonna charge me for [__] sodas right
now are you serious those people should
be beheaded seriously like come on
you're gonna charge me for [__] sodas
well we're not talking like an improv
are we talking now we're talking like a
funny phone like a Bonkers with a z or
or a loony bin or one of those [__]
rooms would you I did them all but that
was the first time I got up sold and
charged and charged yeah that guy was a
scumbag I mean who knows what he's doing
now
but the guy before me I told a friend
he's like I've done that club the guy
shorted me on money and just put a gun
on the table like casually like uh
here's your supposed to be 800 here's
your your 600 and he's like oh it's
supposed to be 800. he's like hold on
let me put my gun down and he was like
all right I'm out of here
so I guess I got off easy
no gun
oh dude this has been a great episode oh
hey thanks see you'd be this [__] I'm
still laughing about the guy hanging out
of your [__] car it's insane yeah
that's insane I feel bad about the
ending but it's it we got out he got
away with it I got a great story out of
it you did get lucky very lucky uh dude
one more time please plug promote
everything anything you'd like hey
markdormancomedy.com for tickets I'm all
over the country doing a big theater
tour going to Europe Tuesdays with
stories we might be drunk podcast we
gotta get you on that by the way I'd
love to all right we'll get you real
high I'd love to all right and then uh
yeah watch the special Soup To Nuts
Netflix a lot of Holocaust jokes we go
for it we really push it I can't believe
uh no one's attacked me yet
are you disappointed no no I hate the
backlash but the r word will get you
yeah it will uh thank you man for real
uh and as always uh Ryan sickler.com
Ryan sickler on all social media come
see me on tour tickets are available on
my website for all stops ryancico.com
we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign